Speaker: The Google Play Developer Console lets you
Publish your apps and games on Google Play
For over one billion Android users around the world.
The Developer Console is full of features
Which helps you grow your business in applications or games.
We chose ten tips you can take advantage of immediately.
Increase the quality of your app by getting feedback
From trusted users before launching it to the world.
How do?
Follow the instructions in the APK tab
Invite users through an open or closed beta test.
They will be able to download the demo from the Play Store
You can receive feedback on the new features you provide.
Do not let mistakes make you fail or slow down your progress.
Scheduling updates lets you launch your app
For a gradually increasing number of persons
So you can detect any bugs
Before its impact on a wider base of the public.
You can use the store data list experiments
Test up to three different forms of code for your app
Text and graphics that appear in your store listing
Stands for the form that prompts users to download your app.
Follow a data-driven approach to optimize your store listing
Try new things.
Do not just assume that things are good enough
Ratings and reviews will tell you what aspects users like in your app
The lesser aspects,
In addition to responding to comments,
Which builds loyalty to the application.
The developer console monitors the performance of your app
On Google Play and suggest optimization tips,
It also provides an easy guide to take advantage of each proposal.
App indexing allows users to open the content of your app
Directly from Google searches on their devices.
So it's a great way to re-engage users who have installed your app
And help them rediscover the features of your app.
After adding app indexing to your app,
Verify ownership of your website in the developer console
To take advantage of the added amount of psychological engagement in the application.
Get insights that lead you to take correct action on how users interact
With your app linking your Google Analytics account
In the developer console.
You'll see additional reports about new and active users,
As well as new metrics like Google Play Referral Flow
Helps you understand how users discover your app.
Has there been a sudden drop in installations or assessments?
Have the periods of interruption increased?
Email alerts will notify you of this
So you can control your app's performance
Reducing the user's bad impression.
Get detailed statistics on behavior
Your application and users
By exporting the most important statistics:
Installations, upgrades, comments, assessments, crashes.
Analysis of these data in detail allows you to identify indicators
And then focus on the most important improvements
Users.
Make your app deployment and administrative tasks
Easy, useful and efficient operations
Through its automatic implementation.
Submit a daily update to beta labs.
Update store listing text and images.
Add or delete in-app products
To maintain constant regenerative application.
Visit the Google Play Developer Console
To start taking advantage of these features.
If you want more tips on how to improve the performance of your app
Or game and improve your business in applications,
Check out other videos in this series
Download the "Google Play App Success Secrets" guide.